now to the questions surrounding
comments by Rudy Giuliani the attorney
brought in weeks ago to defend president
Trump in the Russia investigation is now
being defended by his client president
Trump himself mr. Trump told reporters
Giuliani was quote misinformed when he
spoke about the president's legal
affairs this past week Giuliani is now
walking back some of his statements
Errol Barnett joins us from the White
House Erol good morning good morning on
a day when President Trump could have
easily just focused on good employment
news mr. Trump said Rudy Giuliani did
not have his facts straight
raising yet more questions about the
president's changing story as it relates
to payments connected to stormy Daniels
we cannot get complacent we have to win
the midterms
president Trump traveled to Dallas Texas
yesterday for the NRA s Leadership Forum
on route he defended his legal team when
Rudy made the statements Rudy's great
but Rudy had just started and he wasn't
totally familiar with every you know
with everything Rudy Giuliani told Fox
News the president paid back his
personal lawyer Michael Cohen in 2016
for payments made to stormy Daniels
Giuliani recently joined Trump's legal
team to bring an end to the Russia
investigation a president reimbursed at
over a period of seven years but
yesterday Giuliani walked back the
statements he made earlier this week
saying quote there is no campaign
violation the payment was made to
resolve a personal and false allegation
in order to protect the president's
family and that his references to timing
were not describing my understanding of
the president's knowledge but instead my
understanding of these matters the
president also addressed reports he may
sit down with Special Counsel Robert
Muller
I would love to speak I would love to
nobody wants to speak more than me
effect against my lawyers because
lawyers say never speak with anything in
the midst of defending his legal team
the president hinted at his upcoming
meeting with North Korean leader kim
jong hoon telling reporters only that a
date and location are set we're in
constant contact with the leadership we
are in constant contact with North Korea
with the release of three American
hostages held in North Korea hanging in
the balance we're doing very well with
the hostages now the president also
addressed reports that the u.s. may pull
troops out of South Korea the president
saying that is not part of ongoing
negotiations with North Korea and today
president Trump heads to Cleveland to
attend a roundtable and discuss tax cuts
flat alright Errol Barnett at the White
House for us thank you arrow